are you excited to play persona 5 for
yourself well if you want to address
your character up in you clothes or take
on an extra difficulty level then you'll
be happy to hear that persona fives
entire DLC schedule has been outlined
I'm Matt and this gamespot news update
is going to run you through all of the
JRPGs add-on content the first set of
DLC arrives on April 4th and is
completely free it includes a new
difficulty level challenge the Japanese
audio track and two sets for healing
items and skill cards and then every
Tuesday for the next three weeks we see
the release of both free and paid DLC in
the form of costumes background music
and stickers may 2nd marks the last day
of paid DLC while more costumes will
come for free in both June and July the
costumes can range from swimsuits and
school uniforms to crossovers with other
Atlas games like persona 4 Katherine and
shin megami tensei 4 you can go to
gamespot.com to check out the rest of
the dates and items but make sure to
LIKE and subscribe so you're the first
to know about all of the persona news
persona 5 launches for ps3 and ps4 on
April 4th
GameSpot scored at a 9 out of 10 in its
review and critic Lucy James said
there's an overwhelming level of
artistry in every part of persona 5
making it a truly standout entry in the
series you can read the full review on
GameSpot calm but we don't feel like
doing all that reading check out our
video review right here on our Channel
[Music]